okay this is heavy
I joined Jubilee because of the people
definitely like family to me I love
everyone I think everyone adds a really
unique perspective to our company and
that's what makes us us there's people
from different like religions or
different like countries they grew up in
in different states but we're all like
brought together to do like this like
mission of like human good and empathy
there's a lot of room to have amazing
discussions that I think are pretty
taboo and like most office settings
jublee is all about empathy and what
I've learned through my experience is
that the more that we dive into our
feelings and our secrets and our
emotions the more that we're actually
able to connect with each other and the
reason is because it's our brokenness
that often connects us all
I tried to write it in a way so people
won't know a Jubilee who wrote it
yeah I told myself I wouldn't be enough
there Jubilee I'm a little nervous I
know who wrote it I think who know maybe
I don't
oh I forgot these were my coworkers whoa
I want to set this I have spent so much
time making others happy I'm unsure of
how to make myself happy
this sounds like so many people I do
believe because we love giving to other
people I think our happiness is totally
tie with other people but I think has to
be a balance where it's like you are
honoring yourself and the other person
and both are in balance with their own
with their needs I think if you come
across a person who is able to be
assertive and strong about what they
need you actually end up respecting them
more because they are very solidly their
true selves but I would encourage all of
us watching including Jubilee team to
stand you know for your own kind of self
time I'm an adult and I still have
imaginary friends that I talked to every
day and spend time with at home
sometimes I rearrange the pillows on my
couch so that they can pretend I'm
cuddling with them if anything it means
you have a super active imagination you
can carry that many characters in your
head at once including yourself there
are writers and storytellers all over
the world who technically have imaginary
friends they just call them characters
in their stories I have spent so much
time making others happy I am unsure of
how to make myself happy so this is my
secret I can talk about it or what do
you want to do change it okay I don't
know why I kept reading it cuz I'm like
this is my eye down my religious beliefs
every day I try to remind myself that
doubt is healthy but I'm scared in my
get to the point where I lose what I've
based my entire life upon I often think
that working out Jubilee is the reason I
keep drifting farther and further
from what I used to believe was the
truth I want to be comfortable with
whatever I believe in and I want to be
loved for my family no matter what it is
but I can definitely agree with that I
feel like Jubilee has allowed me I've
always been so open and wanting to know
different perspectives and I feel like
Jubilee has allowed that which possibly
lets doubt come in when I go back to the
Bible are like some things like why
can't we love everybody why do we have
to judge why are some sins worse than
others so it's just like a lot that
comes into religion but I definitely can
relate to that secret okay I used to
have a fully executed plan of how I
would murder one of my siblings haven't
coped with it still don't like them but
I learned murder is not my nature if I
end up in jail for the rest of my life
even in death they still win
damn sometimes the people that you grow
up with are not your people you know in
life you get to have chosen family and
you get to have family that you can't do
anything about and that's just that you
literally can't do anything about it I
don't think that you're the first person
that has ever thought about killing
their sibling like in her for real way
but I do think that it's something that
you can be free of at some point and
don't have to feel captivated by the
older I get the uglier I feel inside I
turn to friends for comfort and support
but I fear they think so too mm-hm
I don't know anyway geoblue is ugly on
the inside and thus I have to assume
that the secret is a total thought
distortion of someone perhaps being too
hard on themselves so I would encourage
this person to I guess just reconsider
you know but unless one of my colleagues
is like a secret serial killer I don't
think
luckily on the inside I've cheated on my
partner I really struggled with that I
had to find a therapist and work through
a lot of my issues oh this is so hard
for me to read and think about our
co-workers because I think obviously for
me from the outside it seems like
everyone is so happy and you don't like
happy of their relationships because
we're always talking about relationships
and like they're always talk about their
sniffing others and it's hard to see
that relationship and then read
something like this and try to put two
and two together because I'm just
thinking and I'm like I can't imagine
anyone in our office cheating on their
partner just because they all seem like
they're so in love and obviously that's
my perspective but it's hard
one person is not always going to
provide everything that you need and so
it may be a moment of like well this
person can provide what I need right now
and maybe that was like I don't know
something like attention or something
simple like that plus-size models annoy
me even though I appreciate
representation I think that the vast
majority of plus-size models do need to
lose a little weight and that our focus
on loving ourselves and our bodies have
become somewhat of an excuse for not
taking control of our own health that's
a hot take I think there are a lot of
people that have this same opinion
probably but feel like it is not a
popular thing to say I definitely don't
think that everybody has the ability to
change their body the way they want it's
just genetics sometimes it could go the
opposite way too like some people just
can't put on weight so I definitely
don't think you're always in control of
that I don't have anybody in my life I
can 100% truly be myself with every time
I've tried I felt judged and it makes me
sad I cope with it by having different
types of people in my life that I reveal
different parts of myself to I don't
write this for this could have been me I
feel like this is very relatable you
know like how in movies you have like
your like best friend that you're like
friends with your whole life or you have
like the people that you grew up with I
have that I feel like I just have like
different pockets of friends in
different like areas of my life like
college friends and church friends and
like a few people I grew up with but I
don't have like that one like really
good best friend that I could like share
anything with I had an abortion in
college and it saved my life
it is not so much something I am ashamed
of more than it is something I just keep
close to myself hmm I'm glad that
they're not ashamed of this experience
I'm also glad that they decide to share
this I don't see this as a secret to for
them I think it's just something that
they choose to share more carefully
because they say they're not ashamed
when I was in Middle School I was
sexually intimate with another family
member and I was the one who initiated
it since then we have had a candid
conversation about the experience and I
have gone to therapy but I don't think
that the guilt will ever stop eating
away at me and how I view myself I know
we all have our secrets of the things
that we've gone through but I don't
think because we're co-workers we don't
think of the depths of those secrets and
the things that we have gone through
this is heavy oh just the last slide I'm
saying I don't think the guilt will ever
stop eating away at me and how I view
myself that is a hard thing to let go of
I do think time heals all I do think
they need to give themselves more time
then I'm hoping that they heal from this
experience seeing rather than later I'm
afraid that I've lost my passion for
life in an apathetic way where I don't
know what to feel anymore
I feel like I'm just coasting by a day
today I'm afraid that I'll never feel
fully alive again and it scares me I
don't know what to do about it and I
don't know if I have the strength to
fight for anything different
I feel confused like I don't know who I
am or what I want in my life if you had
spoken to me about five or six years ago
this would have been my secret and the
reason is even in my journey with
Jubilee I first started Jubilee project
which was a non-profit and that was with
some of my friends and that became
something I was really excited about and
proud of but after a couple of years for
various reasons they went and did
different things and it was me by myself
and I haven't really shared this but for
me it felt like I was the last person on
a ship that was sinking and I was really
scared because it felt like wait a
second everyone else has given up on me
and this idea and I don't even know if I
want to be doing this and I think I felt
really afraid and now when I look back
many years later it was actually that
time of Darkness was so I don't want to
say important because it sucks so much
and it was so painful but it was
necessary for me to find and strip away
everything I cared about whether it was
you know me doing with these friends or
me having this many followers like all
those things that matter anymore to me
and it really was this question of why
do you do what you do like why are you
here on earth this is a good time in
space to look and ask for help and ask
people to help you along your journey
ask people to give you advice ask for
people to give you ideas even and find
ways to say yes meaning you're not gonna
find your passion in one day or one
month or even one year I think but I
think the way that you find your passion
for life is like by saying yes to little
things and the things that give you
gratification and joy you should say yes
again to that and the things that don't
that's okay so we don't have to carry
all those things just let's find a
couple of things that
like as you flip over these stones that
are that are working I guess for you I
do think there's power and sharing
obviously share with people that you're
comfortable with share with people that
you trust share with people that you
love but I do see a power and being
vulnerable